je vais discuter avec l'un des plus
grands magiciens du monde salut
aujourd'hui on fait une interview à la
table aujourd'hui je reçois Luc Langevin
qui est sûrement l'un des plus modernes
des magiciens de ces 20 dernières années
et je me demandais ce qu'il y avait dans
sa tête quand comment il imagine les
tours il y a des tours très puissants
que je connais lui j'aimerais savoir à
quel point il met un apport scientifique
parce qu'il n'a pas assez de
scientifique et c'est quoi le regard qui
porte sur tout ça c'est quoi les
émotions qui vit par rapport à ça c'est
quoi qui pense par rapport à tout ça au
lieu de me poser les questions je vais
lui poser à lui directement tu es
québécois tu es Montréal et pour être
plus précis du coup j'ai une question
qu'est-ce que tu fais ici pourquoi tu es
là dans mon bureau en France c'est une
bonne question j'ai posé la même non je
suis en fait je suis un promotion si on
veut pour un spectacle que je donne au
mois de septembre au Casino de Paris
quand il était venu pour moi aussi ça a
joué dans la balance oui moi j'étais
collé à micro direct en fait tu es là on
fait une vidéo on en profite c'est
important pour moi de commencer par dire
que tu es un scientifique parce qu'on a
tous des racines et
[Musique]
collectif la science à cette cette image
de quelque chose qu'on comprend pas
complètement mais qui explique des trucs
extraordinaires donc je trouve qu'il est
beaucoup là le lien puis évidemment il y
a beaucoup d'illusions qui fonctionnent
grâce à des principes scientifiques
méconnus de toute façon originale aussi
de présenter la magie de parler d'un
phénomène scientifique méconnu et de
faire le lien avec ce que les gens vont
voir donc quand toi tu faisais de la
science est-ce que tu avais des
sentiments d'émerveillement parfois dans
ce que tu apprenais ou dans ce que tu
découvrais qui sont un peu similaires à
ceux que tu nous provoques quand tu fais
des illusions c'est fou que tu poses
cette question là parce que j'ai souvent
dit ça à des gens oui parce que c'est
vraiment la même émotion quand
je faisais mes recherches et que la
soudainement tu trouves tu trouves ce
que tu cherchais depuis longtemps puis
tu as travaillé fort
l'émotion c'est vraiment similaire à une
émotion de voir un bon tour de magie
très bluffant qui était branle un peu et
en fait c'est quand j'ai vécu ces
émotions que je me suis dit il y aurait
un bon un en lien à faire entre la
science et la magie si je pouvais
réussir à faire vivre les émotions que
j'ai vécues comme scientifiques aux gens
avec des illusions je me suis peut-être
une manière de sublimer un peu la magie
c'est un peu comme ça que tu as trouvé
ta marque de fabrique sainte la
formaliser tu vois parce qu'une marque
de Fabrice elle devient dans le temps tu
décides pas de tout et aujourd'hui moi
quand on parle de toi alors je pense à
la vie que tu es mais aussi toujours je
raccorde toujours la science tu vois
pour moi c'est mon mon ami magicien mais
scientifique tu vois parce que ça ça
donne aussi une couleur à qui tu es
quand tu faisais de la science tu
faisais déjà un petit peu de magie oui
en fait j'ai commencé à faire de la
magie avant même de m'intéresser plus
sérieusement à la science en fait la
curiosité je dirais le point commun
entre les deux c'est la curiosité qui
m'a d'abord amené à la magie parce que
comme j'étais curieux de tout comprendre
lorsqu'on a cette curiosité qu'on voit
un tour de magie ça peut être très
frustrant de pas comprendre parce qu'on
voit quelque chose qui ne s'explique pas
donc j'ai d'abord eu un intérêt pour la
magie pour comprendre les ficelles qu'il
y avait derrière les tours parce que je
trouvais ça insupportable
de pas comprendre et puis plus tard à
l'âge peut-être de 12-13 ans dans un
cours de physique et un professeur qui
nous a parlé des atomes et c'est la
première fois je prenais connaissance de
la structure de ce qui nous forme et ça
m'a fasciné j'ai eu ce moment
d'émerveillement et là la passion pour
la science a commencé en parallèle mais
j'avais ça faisait déjà quelques années
la science est venue se joindre en fait
à chaque fois qu'on prend le monde c'est
le désir de compréhension qui est le
point commun moi qu'on m'a parlé des
atomes j'ai compris que la vie c'était
du vide que des vides et j'ai eu un
vertige un peu de mais c'est fou quoi tu
vois dans absolument petit tout est vide
c'est incroyable
vertige j'ai ressenti la même chose
c'est pas comment l'expliquer un vertige
qu'on demande de réfléchir le même vert
évidemment
la science donc c'est toujours une
source d'inspiration pour toi on l'a
bien compris est-ce que tu as d'autres
sources qui viennent d'ailleurs
ou pas d'ailleurs oui oui bah depuis la
science a beaucoup en début de carrière
c'était beaucoup c'était la structure
vraiment
ce dont je partais à chaque fois pour
créer un nouveau tour puis après
plusieurs émissions de télé plusieurs
spectacles je trouvais que je commençais
à avoir fait le tour donc de plus en
plus j'essaie de je cherche les émotions
en fait le point de départ souvent c'est
l'émotion je me dis quelle émotion je
veux faire vivre avec tel numéro ou tel
projet et ensuite je vais lire je vais
m'intéresser à ce qui connaît que ça
l'émotion en question donc
l'inspiration peut venir de partout ça
peut être un proverbe qu'on entend une
parole dans une musique quelqu'un qui
dit quelque chose une ombre au sol parce
qu'en plus la magie c'est tellement
vaste tout ce qu'on peut faire on peut
passer à travers un mur faire apparaître
un éléphant lire dans les pensées c'est
tellement vaste que d'ailleurs c'était
fermé à clé était rentré quand même
je me suis dit je voulais pas vous
déranger
comment est-ce que tu décrirais ton
style illusionnisme est-ce qu'il se
décrit ou pas tu vois moi si je devais
le décrire à ta place
j'espère que c'est positif je dirais que
c'est quelque chose de très créatif et
très moderne c'est à dire que tu me
surprends par les tours que tu fais le
bluff intrinsèque de chaque tour mais
c'est mais au-delà de ça je suis
toujours bluffé aussi parce que tu fais
toujours des choses auxquelles je
m'attends pas le précédent spectacle
c'est le cas j'étais bluffé par les
numéros mais j'étais aussi bluffé que
tes pensées à faire ses numéros que tu
as imaginé et j'ai été bluffé par la
mise en scène du spectacle et c'est dans
ton procédé est-ce que c'est juste ton
style naturel ou est-ce que c'est un
autre style et que je me plante en fait
non non tu as vu juste mais en fait ça
me ça me touche que tu le décrives comme
ça parce que c'est c'est comme ça
maintenant que j'aime être perçu en fait
créatif moderne
en fait je dirais que c'est venu un peu
c'est pas quelque chose que j'ai qui
était prémédité mais au début de ma
carrière je me suis fait connaître par
une émission et donc mais c'était une
émission je faisais de la magie dans les
rues et le c'était des tours des tours
commerciaux des tours qu'on peut acheter
dans les boutiques de magie parce qu'il
y en avait je devais en faire tellement
en fait on faisait quoi sept tours
différents par épisode et on faisait 13
épisodes dans une saison et on a fait
trois saisons donc au total j'ai dû
faire plus de 400 tours donc là c'est
vraiment la machine à soussistes fallait
vraiment dites ça là non on le comprend
très bien
la machine associe charcuterie je sais
pas une traduction libre mais bref j'ai
fait beaucoup beaucoup de tours et j'en
suis venu à un point où pas que ça
m'ennuyait mais j'avais besoin de plus
pour être pour aimer ce que je fais
finalement et quelquefois dans ces
émissions j'avais quand même eu l'audace
je me suis dit j'avais risqué je vais
faire quelque chose qui est pas un truc
commercial qui est pas quelque chose
qu'on fait habituellement dans ma vie je
vais essayer quelque chose que j'ai
imaginé et quand ça fonctionnait et que
les gens réagissaient autant que que
pour un tout commercial il y a toujours
le même sentiment de de fierté de
plaisir de voir quelqu'un réagir autour
que tu fais mais là en plus que ça soit
quelque chose que j'ai créé que j'ai
imaginé et de voir que ça produit ses
émotions l'émotion est encore plus forte
et encore là c'est difficile à décrire
mais il y a quelque chose d'enivrant de
se dire j'avais quelque chose dans ma
tête je l'ai concrétisé et ça produit
ses émotions là chez les gens et donc
soudainement la création est devenue un
peu une drogue finalement ça j'étais
plus satisfait de faire des tours que
quelqu'un d'autre avait inventé la seule
chose qui me satisfaisait c'est de
d'imaginer des choses de les concrétiser
que ça produise ça génère des émotions
chez les gens risquent vaut la chandelle
ou la saucisse le risque
du podcast alors moi je dirais aussi ton
style tu parlais des émotions c'est de
faire peur à ton public
si je peux me permettre parce que si je
t'ai invité aujourd'hui c'est aussi pour
parler donc de tes passages dans
l'émission diversion qui est présentée
par Arthur ou tu as risqué ta vie pour
un numéro est-ce que tu vois de quel jeu
parle je pense que oui celui avec
l'acide seulement oui
déjà qu'il y en a plusieurs et je suis
d'accord qu'il y en a plusieurs
des fois des fois c'était dangereux
parce que j'avais pas beaucoup dormi des
fois c'était dangereux pour d'autres
raisons oui il y avait quand même un
risque parce que c'est ça reste une
illusion faut le dire mais il y avait
quand même un risque parce qu'on
travaillait avec des produits chimiques
des produits chimiques qui étaient quand
même inodore incolore donc si s'il y
avait une erreur qui se faisait il y a
quelqu'un pouvait pouvait se blesser
mais il y a pas de risque zéro sur ce
genre de risque zéro donc comment tu as
eu l'idée de ce tour du coup tu vois tu
t'es dit bon tout le monde me prend pour
un mec sympa je montrais que si tu
arrives je suis terrifiant dans le fond
parce que quand on est en train de te
regarder faire ce numéro
on l'a regardé d'ailleurs au bureau avec
mon équipe les gens votre vie un peu
quoi il y a une vraie tension palpable
mais c'est aussi le but d'un artiste de
générer de l'émotion en quelque sorte en
fait ce numéro c'est étonnamment c'est
pas l'émotion que qui qui a été
l'inspiration mais comme le dans
diversion on m'appelle le scientifique
donc je sais toujours vraiment d'avoir
un effort avec la science puis j'avais
jamais fait vraiment de roulettes russes
et le type de tour qu'on appelle le
roulette russe ou le magicien se met en
danger écrasant et puis voilà il y a des
choix il y a un danger dans un choix et
j'avais déjà c'est un tour que j'avais
déjà fait dans une émission spéciale au
Canada ah ben j'allais te demander si
c'était la première fois que tu descends
en fait tout ce que je fais dans
diversion généralement je l'ai fait
auparavant oui non mais c'est une
sécurité aussi bien sûr c'est déjà très
inconfortable pour moi de venir en
France de déjà c'est je veux dire c'est
un milieu parler des Français
non mais je veux dire c'est un milieu
hostile entre guillemets parce que
j'arrive dans un endroit où je suis venu
j'ai un accent donc c'est ce que les
gens remarquent en premier quand je me
mets à parler donc c'est pas des
conditions qui sont idéales j'arrive sur
un plateau souvent je suis en décalage
horaire donc tout est très tout est
contre moi en quelque sorte donc
j'essaie au moins dans les numéros que
je propose d'avoir une certaine
certitude face à l'issue du numéro pour
le coup du coup je rebondis sur ce que
tu dis mais c'est assez passionnant de
se dire pour dire les termes d'une star
au Québec tu as rassemblé un bon demi
million de personnes grosso modo tu vois
si vous voulez un point de comparaison
moi sur toute ma carrière qu'une
carrière qui fonctionne plutôt bien je
je suis entre 100 et 150000 personnes tu
vois les spectacles sur scène pour les
spectacles sur scène ouais je parle un
de mes millions c'est énorme c'est
vraiment quelque chose de rare ici aussi
en France et donc toi tu pourrais rester
confortablement en fait avec ton demi
million de l'autre côté de l'Atlantique
et tu dis ben non je viens en France et
et je vais rencontrer des gens qui ne
savent pas du tout ce que j'ai fait qui
je suis etc ou la qualité que je mets
dans mes spectacles depuis des années
etc donc ça oui c'est très inconfortable
tu te dis je me mets dans une situation
où effectivement on entend tout de suite
que j'ai un accent etc c'est quoi la
démarche c'est c'est l'envie d'aller sur
un nouveau territoire c'est juste te
trop heureux tu dis tiens je vais mettre
des bâtons
qu'est-ce qui se passe dans ta tête j'ai
souvent eu le sentiment de l'imposteur
au Canada quand je parce que surtout au
début comme je disais je faisais des
tours assez commerciaux que les autres
magiciens faisaient et soudainement mes
émissions ils ont ils ont cartonné
peut-être un an un an et demi je suis
devenu la référence en magie au Québec
donc j'avais un peu le sentiment de
l'imposité dit j'étais juste au bon
endroit au bon moment et puis c'est tout
et
ce sentiment c'est pas agréable donc
j'étais quand même heureux de ce qui
m'arrivait et tout alors que je te coupe
2 secondes mais tu sais que les gens
t'aiment d'abord pour toi et après pour
le tour en lui-même il y a la manière
d'être magique en fait je l'ai découvert
après ce coup-ci mais sur le coup moi je
pense il me dit les gens aiment les
tours que je font et que je fais et moi
je suis et je suis je suis qu'un canal
pour et
inconsciemment je pense que j'ai voulu
venir en France pour me prouver que
j'étais capable d'arriver un dans un
endroit où je suis inconnu je comprends
partir de zéro et réussir malgré tout
j'ai l'impression que c'est vraiment ce
espèce de désir de me prouver à moi-même
que j'étais capable de le faire mais
c'est passionnant de du coup pour les
personnes qui nous écoutent de dire
tu as eu besoin de ce risque là pour te
prouver de ta valeur aussi de la valeur
de ton travail je vois le
[Musique]
tout est flouté un stand de peur donc
tout est très très fluide et très très
drôle et à un moment donné il fait un
blanc il dit ma grand-mère est morte et
il va pardon il y a pas de transition
c'est un peu brutal il y a aucune
transition avec ce que je disais et là
il chuchote et il dit mais qu'est-ce que
l'auteur voulait dire l'auteur a voulu
dire que par cette transition qui
n'existe pas il a mis en avant que
durant 1h30 vous n'avez jamais senti une
transition car les étés très bien faites
et c'est sa manière de et c'est vrai que
quand il dit ça là c'est pareil tu dis
même moi pour le coup qu'un regard sur
les spectacles c'est vrai que depuis
1h30 ça s'enchaîne je n'ai jamais rien
vu
donc le fait de fois de ne rien avoir à
dire c'est un gage de qualité sur ce que
tu as vu tu vois c'est pas fou comme ces
distinguage de qualité quand le travail
derrière est invisible bien sûr l'invité
à qui t'avait fait le tour de la cible
c'était Camille lou oui qui était
paniqué qu'est-ce que tu ressens toi à
ce moment-là ça m'a ça qui m'intéresse
aussi ce qu'il y a dans ta tête quand tu
vois que toute l'assemblée est stressée
est-ce que toi tu es dans ton numéro
donc de toute manière le reste n'existe
pas ou est-ce que tu te dis j'ai atteint
mon but ou est-ce que tu dis je voulais
pas déstresser à ce point tu vois c'est
quoi le discours intérieur en fait moi à
chaque fois que je suis dans un numéro
surtout dans un contexte comme celui de
diversion ou c'est un tournage il y a
beaucoup de caméra il y a du public sur
place c'est comme si j'ai besoin de
faire comme s'il y a rien de ce qui
existait puis d'être complètement
focus sur ce qui sur ma performance sur
le texte faut pas que ma langue font ne
faut pas que ma langue fonde
faut pas que j'accroche le bécher puis
c'est drôle parce que tu dis quand tu
vois que tout le monde est stressé mais
je le vois pas ce que j'avais les yeux
bandés
même si j'avais les yeux ouverts c'est
toujours comme ça je suis je deviens en
état d'hyper vigilance mais sur tout ce
qui est tout ce qui concerne le numéro
puis je vois c'est pas que je perçois
pas les réactions mais je suis tellement
concentré sur ce que je fais et sur ce
qui s'en vient puis d'être alerte à si
jamais il dit quelque chose d'ESS
rebondir là dessus pour que ce soit
drôle ou pour que ça j'ai pas beaucoup
le plaisir finalement le plaisir je l'ai
après quand c'est fait logement avait pu
c'était bon c'était moral là j'ai j'ai
le petit velours mais pendant c'est un
moment de c'est comme si c'était une
performance olympique puis que tu veux
juste bien faire puis on célébrera après
si donc c'est vraiment c'est vraiment
comment je me sens dans durant ces
moments-là mais c'est un truc que j'ai
entendu d'autres artistes de scène qui
sortent de scène et qui moi j'ai pu dire
alors tu as aimé ce qui s'est passé je
sais pas vraiment encore je
une espèce de blackout de
l'environnement comme tu dis tu as
d'autres numéros qu'on suscité autant de
stress que celui-là sur scène où la télé
je parle de stress pour les autres
tu as eu quoi par exemple ouais on a
fait un numéro je pense qu'on l'a fait
dans diversion aussi ou c'est un numéro
d'évasion j'étais attaché dans une boîte
il y a une espèce de mâchoire
qui menace de se refermer à tout moment
donc ça c'était peut-être le deuxième
numéro le plus dangereux il y en a trois
j'ai fait aussi un hommage à Houdini qui
était particulièrement dangereux aussi
je dirais c'est il y a toujours
véritablement un risque à chaque fois on
a quelqu'un
sauveteur sur place au cas où ça se
passe mal mais depuis que je suis papa
aussi je fais moins c'est tout là je
comprends tu t'es assagi ouais ça vaut
je me dis je suis capable de générer des
émotions aussi fortes sans prendre de
risque pour ma santé donc voilà et
est-ce qu'il y a une numéro alors pas
forcément qui fait peur je rebondis
dessus qui selon toi a créé un avant et
un après dans ta carrière moi il y a un
numéro de toi qui m'a marqué je te le
dirai après parce que peut-être le même
on verra qui sait je sais pas c'est
celui-là bah moi je sais que j'ai vu une
différence c'est un tour qu'on appelle
le rajeunissement voilà moi c'est c'est
exactement celui-là je suis très content
de ce numéro on l'a fait sur le plateau
de Drucker quand justement quand j'ai
commencé à venir en France parce qu'on
s'était dit bon c'est le numéro
peut-être qu'il y a un mec avait bien
marché ok il y en avait plusieurs qui
ont bien marché mais celui-là il
générait une émotion c'était une des
premières fois où des ne me voit en me
disant qu'ils avaient versé une larme
mais une larme de
tristesse là mais de il y avait ce
numéro qui vient chercher quelques il y
a quelque chose de nostalgique c'est
l'idée si on pouvait rajeunir et revivre
un moment important de notre vie quel
moment est-ce que ce serait donc je pose
la question dans le numéro donc tout le
monde se pose un peu la question aussi
puis finalement dans le numéro moi je me
retrouve par le biais de l'illusion à
revivre un moment fort dans ma vie qui
est en plus c'est la vraie histoire en
plus c'est le vraiment moins fort dans
ma vie qui est là la première fois que
j'ai goûté aux applaudissements
finalement avec une illusion je donne
l'illusion de rajeunir à l'âge de 13 ou
14 ans et la version jeune de moi-même
retrouve les cartes qu'on piocher les
invités puis je redeviens à l'âge à
l'âge adulte c'est un numéro que
j'affectionne beaucoup c'est ce que je
rêvais de produire avec le numéro et ça
c'est matérialisé exactement comment en
fait pas exactement mais dans les
c'était le plan le meilleur plan
possible finalement la meilleure et
voilà c'est un numéro que que j'adore et
puis je sais pas écoute je vais partager
quelque chose avec toi si c'est pas bon
c'est au pire je sais pas si vous faites
du montage tu pourras le couper non on
garde qu'est-ce que tu demandes de
couper c'est bizarre parce que
évidemment ce tour c'est une illusion
donc quand je deviens quand je suis à
l'état jeune finalement c'est pas moi
c'est c'est un jeune Québécois qui joue
mon rôle quand on l'a fait sur le
plateau de Drucker on a une version et
puis je me rappelle surtout je suis
retourné voir le jeune après lui il
était hyper content lui il y a quelqu'un
le numéro il marchait était super
stressé c'est comme on s'est serré dans
dans j'en parle
[Musique]
on s'est serré dans nos bras parce que
moi j'étais content lui était content
lui avait vu il y avait eu quelque chose
de fort parce que c'est un jeune qui
voulait faire du cinéma qui voulait
faire de la télé c'est un peu sa
première expérience c'est un Québécois
donc là c'était la première fois qu'il
est en France et là il vivait ça et puis
quelques et je pensais souvent à lui
après parce que il est décédé deux ans
après dans un accident de voiture ça m'a
fait un choc c'est bizarre c'est comme
non seulement j'étais attaché à lui mais
en plus c'était comme la part de toi
clé ou j'essayais de percer en France
pendant on a vécu une émotion forte avec
avec ça puis dans comme quelques
semaines après un acteur qui a joué une
version plus vieille de moi dans une
vidéo et décédée d'un cancer aussi donc
toutes les versions vieilles et jeunes
de moi sont décédés dans le même une
période de ma vie où je rédigeais mon
testament d'ailleurs donc tout ça était
très bizarre c'est non mais c'est déjà
c'est passionnant alors il y a le côté
synchronicité de toutes ces et tout mais
en plus pour le rajeunissement avec ce
jeune là c'est sûrement le temps le plus
fort en plus que tu avais vécu à
quelqu'un et du coup j'imagine vraiment
quand on perdant ce compagnon oui tu
perds quand même la version jeune de
toi-même il y a une symbolique qui est
incroyablement forte voilà moi j'avais
été fasciné par ce numéro et je me
souviens vraiment de mettre dit là on
cherche nous tous dans le milieu
artistique surtout sur les émissions de
télé ou quoi à faire le truc le moins
compliqué parce qu'on sait que tout est
compliqué c'est compliqué à programmer à
mettre en place les gens sur un pas
compte à quel point c'est pas c'est pas
simple de faire ce qu'on veut en fait
dans une émission et c'est pas simple
d'avoir du temps pour préparer du temps
pour installer de de gérer les angles
enfin c'est très très complexe tu es
arrivé avec l'équivalent d'un final de
grands spectacle dans des émissions de
télé je me disais le le gars a décidé de
s'en du taux d'emmerdement il y
avait un peu de naïveté je pense au
j'étais pas conscient de tout ce que ça
prenait pour faire ce numéro là puis
mais oui c'est un moment où je me dis il
faut frapper fort en France on avait
voilà on avait essayé je me rendais
compte à ce moment-là que c'était
difficile de percer donc il faut frapper
un grand coup donc c'est lequel le
numéro de parle le plus moi je parle
beaucoup justement ou de rajeunissement
sinon c'est le final de du spectacle
précédent la téléportation
je trouve quand même à la avec un petit
fond de moi dans ma tête qui me dit mais
comment il a ramené tout ça j'imagine
des bateaux des containers des trucs
comme ça c'est incroyable et je veux pas
les avoir et personne n'a envie de le
savoir mais je pensais pas qu'on pouvait
faire ça sur un show live avec une
contrainte dont grand public sur un pas
compte et même les artistes rendent pas
compte c'est un spectacle qui a été fait
pour tourner c'était pas un spectacle
qui était en fixe dans son théâtre à Las
Vegas on pourrait peut-être imaginer
plus facilement ce genre de défi tu vois
donc voilà tu vas te dire exactement la
même chose mais x 2 pour le
en fait c'est peut-être la plus grosse
contrainte lorsqu'on imagine un
spectacle d'illusion comme ça il faut
tourner avec il faut arriver le jour
même dans la ville que tout soit prêt
pour le soir faut faire le spectacle il
faut tout emballer et partir pour la
ville suivante tu as fait une grosse
valise oui il faut rentrer si tu veux
faire apparaître un bateau il faut qu'il
passe par la porte du théâtre ça arrive
le matin donc c'est voilà c'est beaucoup
de contraintes il faut que ça fonctionne
peu importe l'angle de vue auquel les
balcons donc tout ça c'est un gros
casse-tête puis mais j'aime en fait
j'aime le défi de me dire est-ce que je
peux faire ce tour et réussir à tourner
avec de le rendre Toro ball de trouve on
est capable de le démonter de le monter
rapidement et de j'aime travailler avec
les contraintes je trouve c'est
stimulant créativement et parfois ça
fait en sorte qu'on trouve des méthodes
pour le taux qui sont encore mieux que
l'idée originale puis surtout quand tu
vas en région quand tu tournes quand tu
tu tu vas là
tu rencontres des gens qui ne se sont
jamais nécessairement déplacés dans une
grande ville pour voir mais là tu leur
montres quelque chose qui vers qui
reveront peut-être jamais de leur vie
justement parce qu'il s'imaginent pas
qu'on peut on peut se balader avec tout
ça donc ils vivent une émotion encore
plus forte donc c'est ça moi c'est ce
qui motive aussi de c'est pour l'instant
ce que je retiens d'être conversation
c'est que tu es ton pyrénie dès que ça
va bien tu trouves une manière de
d'avoir une idée quand même dans la vie
je comprends bien sinon c'est pas
amusant c'est trop facile tu as souvent
fait référence à Houdini tu as même
reproduit un numéro d'évasion très
célèbre ou tu t'enfermé dans un bidon de
les remplit d'eau s'il n'est pas de
bêtises audini c'est ça fait partie de
tes sources d'inspiration ou c'était
juste pour revivre un petit peu cette
séquence houdinienne ça a été la
première superstar de la magie outre
Robert houden puis il a réussi à créer
des images fortes images c'est à une
époque où les il y avait la création des
premiers syndicats et lui il montrait
cette image d'un homme fort qui pouvait
se libérer de n'importe quel emprise
donc je pense c'est quelque chose qui a
résonné fort à l'époque dans le contexte
de la société à ce moment-là
donc c'est il est inspirant pour moi en
ce sens puis on met l'idée de lui faire
un hommage en fait c'est parce qu'il est
décédé des suites d'un coup de poing
qu'il a réussi à Montréal et donc c'est
moi j'habite à Montréal donc on tourne
des missions de magie enfin bon il faut
bien faut bien tirer profit tout ça donc
on a fait voilà un hommage à Houdini on
a j'ai quand même transformé un peu le
numéro pour le mettre à ma sauce un peu
je vous laisse on connaît l'impression
de voir le processus de l'évasion et
tout ça mais je le referai plus c'est un
des seuls tours que j'ai revendu à un
autre magicien après pour une certaine
de plus le faire ah oui c'est c'était
pour toi en même temps l'assurance de
dire à la si un jour j'ai un doute j'ai
plus de doute je peux plus le faire non
mais quand on rentre dans ce bidon
métallique déjà on est submergé donc tu
as 58 tu vas sous l'eau le soudainement
tu vas entendre le son plus sourd et là
quand on referme découvert tout résonne
c'est le métal qui résonne qui résonne
beaucoup plus fort parce que tu es sous
l'eau et les cadenas qui donc tu entends
tous métal
tu retiens ton souffle était tout coincé
comme ça sur tiens ton souffle et tu dis
merci si je prends un mauvais
respiration le temps qui me sorte d'ici
c'est je vais perdre connaissance là
c'est donc il y a un réel il y a un réel
danger puis il y a des moments pourquoi
je fais ça voilà
mais après tu le sais après tu sais
pourquoi tu le fais puis en deux gars
exactement c'est une réponse on a on a
beaucoup parlé du passé il y a ton
nouveau spectacle donc qui est bientôt
caisse notre Paris 5 représentations
déjà on voit que tu as le bon goût de
prendre une très très belle salle à
Paris tu as le bon goût de prendre une
excellente première partie parce que
j'ai entendu dire que c'était moi oui
déjà vu que tu es mentalistes mais alors
moi j'ai dit oui parce que mine de rien
on se connaît depuis longtemps on est
amis depuis un petit moment on n'a
jamais eu le plaisir de partager une
mais je serais pas encore moi d'écrire
ton nouveau spectacle comment tu le
décrirais toi
c'est un spectacle où il y a beaucoup
plus de grandes illusions que ce que
j'ai fait auparavant j'ai toujours fait
de la grande illusion dans les
spectacles mais c'est souvent comme
final ou pour commencer fort mais là il
y en a vraiment un peu partout dans tout
au long du spectacle il y a pas de tour
de cartes on est vraiment plus d'entrée
la magie la plus grande déploiement je
me suis dit après la pandémie les gens
vont les gens qui se déplacent en salle
vont peut-être avoir le goût d'avoir du
spectaculaire et le spectacle s'appelle
vérité avec un S un thème que la
pandémie m'a inspirée aussi avec tout ce
mouvement respirationniste et de voir
qu'en fait la vérité peut être très
différente dans de Panama dans les yeux
de qui elle se trouve
et je trouvais que c'était riche pour
comme thème pour des illusions les
illusions qui est une illusion qui est
un mensonge finalement donc ça colle
bien avec la vérité c'est un spectacle
où je vais où la trame narrative et sur
la vérité on l'ex je l'exploite parfois
de façon poétique ou la vérité est
représentée par quelque chose qui est
inatteignable qu'on déconse s'approche
ça s'éloigne comme un miracle parfois
d'une façon
philosophique ou parfois de façon très
humoristique il y a un numéro je fais
monter un couple que je branche sur un
détecteur de mensonges et on vit un
moment très drôle
il y a des j'ai essayé d'être créatif et
moderne comme tu l'as dit il y a un
numéro dont je suis très fier ou en fait
je dis une phrase ou si la virée si nos
yeux nous montrait vraiment la vérité on
n'aurait pas l'illusion que tout
disparaît lorsqu'on éteint la lumière et
en disant nous aurons le spectacle
j'étais à la lumière et tout ce qui est
sur scène disparaît et puis finalement
on se rend compte que les choses ne sont
pas disparus quels sont juste invisibles
ce je laisse tomber des morceaux de
tissus il est dessus épouse du tabouret
Nutella il y a un instant et commence un
numéro comme ça où les meubles sont
invisibles mais ils sont là et on fait
quelque chose avec
mais c'est génial en plus tu as utilisé
le mot magique grand déploiement
après avoir utilisé grande illusion et
je trouve que ça te va bien tu vois non
mais c'est parce que la grande illusion
elle commence à être chargée de sens
maintenant elle renvoie à des images de
choses que je ne pense pas te voir faire
durant le spectacle tu vois de de alors
je vais aller au plus basique la femme
coupée en deux compense agrandius on
pense souvent à ça à grande déploiement
je vois tout de suite l'envergure en
fait d'un tour à la Luque mais version
propre inattendue quoi inatteignable tu
vois voilà je vais faire la première
partie de Luc Langevin ça fait bien
longtemps que j'avais pas fait des
premières parties comme ça mais c'est
l'occasion de se retrouver sur scène si
vous avez l'occasion le spectacle vérité
là vous avez la fiche les dates qui
s'affichent devant vous c'est au Casino
de Paris et je serai là à chaque fois je
ferai une première partie avec Luc
venez je vous mettrais un lien dans la
description et merci à lui de cette
rendue disponible c'est devenu un ami au
fil du temps Luc depuis 2017 ou 2018
qu'on fait des vidéos ensemble mais on
s'était jamais posé ces questions aussi
précises et c'est très gentil à lui
aussi de cette ouvert à ce point et de
d'avoir été aussi généreux prenez soin
de vous à très bientôt Ciao